considering how much is packed into
every episode of Game of Thrones it
might come as a surprise that there are
plenty of scenes filmed for the show
that never make it to air
luckily HBO has included many of these
deleted scenes as bonus features for
their home releases and some of these
scenes provide important character
details and even hints of future events
he has a look at the most important
deleted scenes from Game of Thrones
Loras and Margaery season 2 in this
deleted scene from season 2 Loras and
Margery comfort each other following the
murder of Renly Baratheon at the hands
of Stannis Baratheon and Melisandre
shadow assassin Loras is clearly more
grief-stricken than his sister which
makes sense given Renly was his true
love more importantly a viewers got an
early glimpse into Marjorie's always
scheming mind as she carefully steers
Loras away from grief and towards a more
pragmatic future supporting her next
political move he was a good man he was
a kind sweet man but he's gone now he
doesn't need you anymore I need you our
family needs you
Dario and Aries season 2 during the
second season of Game of Thrones
Daenerys learned that important lesson
in trust when her handmaiden Duryea
betrayed her murdering the khaleesies
confidant Eyrie in the process fans
didn't actually see any of that happen
but the sequence was actually filmed
before being cut so later in an
interview after her departure from Game
of Thrones actress Amrita Acharya who
played Eyrie revealed that she was
trying so hard to make the strangulation
scene realistic that she actually
suffered real injuries to her neck while
filming I had massive bruises on my neck
the next day I was proud battle scars
death scenes are fun
Sansa The Hound and Tyrion a season two
Sandor Clegane has had one of the most
dramatic character arcs of anyone on the
show as the Hound slowly embraced his
humanity that journey began with his
relationship of the imprisoned son sir
in season two but it was a rocky
beginning as this deleted scene shows
would you sing a song for me little bird
song about knights and fair maidens come
on sing
you won't hurt me the scene ends of
Tyrion intervening on behalf of his
future wife giving this brief deleted
sequence yet another layer of
foreshadowing pycelle and Tywin season 3
although the audience suspects up high
status playing his own long game the
other residents of King's Landing never
quite seemed to realize the grand
maester isn't nearly as feeble as he
pretends to be
but in this deleted scene we discovered
that Tywin has known all the long more
shockingly placer reveals that it was
his treachery that allowed the
Lannisters to conquer the Seven Kingdoms
in the first place since the time I
convinced the Mad King to open his gates
to you I have served the interest of the
House of Lannister unfailingly given how
much goes on in this short scene it's a
bit surprising they left it on the
cutting room floor bran and Shae season
four after Tyrion ends his relationship
with Shay in season four he sends her
away to penthouse where he hopes she
will be safe
later she shockingly resurfaces to
testify against him at his trial why
well the seeds for that were actually
planted in a deleted scene where Tyrians
buddy Branagh delivers the bad news
along with a speech about how rich
people are all total jerks you can
almost see Shay's love twisting despite
as he talks these people even the good
ones they uses as they please and when
we're no longer any use they spit us out
find someone else they like good job
Bronn grey worm and Masson Day season 5
in this deleted sequence from season 5
we get to see an extended version of a
scene between Musante and grey worm
after the unsullied named white rat was
killed in a marine brothel we get to see
a hint of the beginning of the romance
between grey room and missandei as she
tells him that she is afraid what might
happen to him if the sons of the harpy
attack he will be careful careful
you will protect yourself I predict
Daenerys Stormborn of course shortly
after this grey worm was nearly killed
only surviving thanks to the sacrifice
of Ser Barristan next time a lesson to
you girlfriend
aiya and the mummer's season six in
several parts of season six aya works
with the troupe of mummers in Braavos as
they perform their satire of Westeros II
current events the bloody hand but not
everyone in the audience enjoys a
performance as much as aya as shown in
this deleted scene original why don't
you just leave them if you're familiar
with the controversy surrounding the
show after the events following sons as
wedding to Ramsay snow in season five
it's not hard to recognize this deleted
scene as a subtle dig at viewers who
complain about the show but continue to
tune in anyway I'm going in a wild boar
hunt
thanks for watching thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel you to please check
all this cool stuff all this cool stuff
we know your love to da da dee dee or
they won't do my life right now